So now that we have completed our update function which takes a year,
filters our data, updates our data bind, removes and
circles that the previous updated data bind would cause to be irrelevant,
access through the exit selection, add any new circles that need to be on
the page based on what happened in the updated data bind by
simply taking the enter selection and appending circles.
And then effectively filtering the countries we show by changing the styling,
such that only the countries that had a team in the World Cup are shown.
So just to recap where we are, we completed the first task that we needed to
get done before we could animate our map by writing an update function
that takes a single year and manipulates the elements on our map.
To properly represent the given year and the attendance in that year.
Remember, the second part of animating our map,
was to simply cycle over all the years of the World Cup.
There are many ways to perform the type of animation that we want to do in d3,
but for simplicity's sake, I'm going to use one of the most explicit,
even though there's more efficient and robust ways to do this.
I've linked to a few examples in the instructor notes with some
resources an tutorials that cover other ways to create animations in D3